it was quite a global phenomenon and I
and for a lot of reasons I mean it was
obviously a good show and it had good
chemistry and good stories and and and
and and and but it was somehow unique to
its time - I think in the 90s was just
the beginning of the internet we were
beginning to move into a kind of digital
world we were beginning to question
what's real and what's not real and
that's what the show did and it was just
the right show at the right time I think
did you enjoy particularly about your
character as a great character in the
show every actor loves to play the
villain it's an excuse to to do what we
can't do in real life I think and it
gives us power I had quit smoking many
years before but of course as a teenager
I smoked to feel strong and powerful so
I could recreate that you know with a
cigarette and feel that I was strong and
tough the mystery the mystery of the
character and the challenge to figure
out the backstory which wasn't always
the same was always fun how much did you
know when you kind of signed on to play
that character what that backstory was
added that you did you kind of learn as
it went along well for starters I do
nothing but that's also because they
knew nothing as far as I know
I think they just thought it was kind of
an interesting thing to have this
mysterious character in the background
is smoked and as the fans became
interested and they became interested
that they started to fill in the gaps
and gradually it grew into it when you
look back over the many episodes of the
x-files that you made which one stand
out for you well the show that everybody
keeps mentioning which is the show that
at the time I was the most suspicious of
which was the memoirs of a cigarette
smoking man because it it didn't really
fit with the stories that we had
developed about the character and we
kind of passed it off as froakie's idea
of the character but so many people come
and tell me how they loved that episode
and how it fascinated that circuit
looking back on that episode yourself
what do you feel about it looking back I
think it was brilliant at the time I
wasn't sure but looking back I think so
I was it like working with Davis and
Australian as well on the show
Julian regrettably I worked on very
little and that's partly what inspired
me to to write or at least sponsor their
episode onto me because I had done so
little with her David was fun to work
with he was a challenging actor when he
really wanted to work he was really
really good yeah
what do you think about future prospects
of maybe another x-files film do you
think that would be a good thing to do
what would you like to see happen in it
I wish we could all get younger that's
the only thing that bothers me about it
I don't know I don't know how to do it
or how they would do it now that we're
older we don't we're not all alive I
mean not only the characters but the
actors in some cases so but I'd love to
see them take a crack at it
yeah what would you like if you could
say to Frank what would you like to
happen in that movie well not to be
completely versus I think it should
reflect back in time and show a
different resolution led by the
cigarette smoking ban
you must get fans asking you about the
other shows you've been in as well as
things like continuum and star games
what did you enjoy about those shows it
was different to x-files a continuum of
a continuum is fascinating and it's just
beginning to grow and it just started to
show here we've done two seasons there's
obviously going to be more it's a
fascinating story that's a it's a
fascinating story because you're not
sure who the good guys and bad guys are
yeah it it has political ramifications
because it it's in a way challenges that
the world that we have already become
nevermind the one we might become
but it's the bad guys who are
challenging the world that we have
become but maybe they're not bad guys
you know it's it's so it's it's complex
so it's it's fascinating